.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Vielleicht rettet Ihnen einer
dieser jungen Menschen mal das Leben.
Sie sind
angehende Pflegefachkräfte ...
... oder Rettungssanitäter.
Die Ausbildung ist streng, der Beruf
spannend, aber anspruchsvoll.
Rebecca, Fanny ...
... Hélène und Lucas
wollen in einer Branche arbeiten,
die viele andere verlassen.
Warum - das erzählt diese Serie.
Yverdon, Notfallstation.
Fanny ist unterwegs mit Amélie,
einer erfahrenen Kollegin.
Uh, es ist frisch.
Ein Pullover wäre praktisch.
Ja, voll.
- Mir ist echt kalt.
Bist du krank oder müde?
- Ich habe nicht viel geschlafen.
Sie sind unterwegs zu jemandem,
der laut Meldung in einem
schlechten Allgemeinzustand ist.
Das wird als Priorität 2 eingestuft,
also nicht lebensgefährlich.
Darum ist die 144
ohne Blaulicht unterwegs.
Es wirkte für uns so,
als wäre es nichts Schlimmes.
Darum fuhren wir auch normal.
Aber als sie ankommen,
sieht die Situation anders aus.
Grüezi.
* Stöhnen *
Geht es ihm seit heute Morgen so?
- (Frau) Ja.
Okay. Grüezi.
Ungefähr vor einer halben Stunde
fand ich ihn so auf der Toilette.
Er schaute uns nicht an
und klang komisch.
Er gab keine richtigen Antworten.
Als wir ihn anstupften,
reagierte er nicht.
Seine Muskulatur war total hart.
Man spürt einen gewissen Druck,
wenn man merkt,
dass die Situation
lebensbedrohlich ist.
Der Zustand des Mannes ist kritisch.
Ja, ist gut.
Seine Atmung ist sehr anormal.
Unregelmässig und eher schnell.
Er braucht ...
Wir helfen Ihnen gleich.
Er braucht sofort Sauerstoff.
Schnell.
Könnten Sie mir
seine Medikamentenliste geben?
Selbstverständlich.
Dem 92-jährigen Alfred
geht es schlecht.
Seine Frau Josiane
steht unter Schock.
In den 20 Min., die wir warteten,
hielt ich ihn fest,
damit er nicht umfällt.
Das ist lange, um so zu warten,
bis sie da sind.
Sie sind einverstanden,
dass es normalerweise nicht so ist?
Absolut.
- Vermutlich eine Ptosis labial.
Im Falle einer Ptosis labial
hängen die Wange und die Lippen
auf einer Seite.
Der Betroffene kann sich nicht mehr
ausdrücken, sondern lallt.
Und wenn man sie so fest anstupft,
dass es wehtut, reagieren sie nicht.
Es könnte u.a. ein Zeichen
eines Schlaganfalls sein.
Bei einem Schlaganfall
muss man sofort ins Spital.
Fanny macht die letzten Abklärungen.
Wir messen den Blutzucker und
die Temperatur. Er ist Diabetiker.
Es ist sehr stressig, weil man
schnell alles abklären muss.
Man weiss aber nicht genau,
was los ist.
Wir kontrollieren
den Blutdruck nochmals.
Ich höre Ihre Lunge ab.
Atmen Sie mit offenem Mund.
Gut. Der letzte Gesundheitscheck
war am Mittag.
* Stöhnen *
1,9 - alles klar.
Also, Planänderung.
Wir legen einen Venenzugang.
- Wir müssen ihn aufzuckern.
Frau Mayor,
der Zuckerwert ist bei 1,9.
Das ist viel zu tief.
- Gut.
Er ist stark unterzuckert.
Darum zuckern wir ihn auf.
Es ist kein Schlaganfall,
sondern eine Unterzuckerung.
Bei Alfred
ist der Zuckerwert so tief,
dass er sterben könnte.
- Wir zuckern Sie darum auf.
Manchmal
werden die Betroffenen bewusstlos
und atmen nicht mehr,
und ihr Herz schlägt langsamer.
Das kann zum Tod führen.
Es muss schnell gehen.
Hat er seine Medikamente genommen?
Nein. Doch, hat er.
- Okay.
In letzter Zeit hat er nicht mehr
so gut kontrolliert wie früher.
Also, am Finger.
- Alles klar.
Das wird schwierig.
Schau dir seine Hände an.
Eine heikle Sache.
- Gut.
Wir schliessen Sie
an eine Infusion an. Einverstanden?
Moment, du brauchst das.
- Okay.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach, einen
Zugang für die Infusion zu legen,
weil Alfreds Hand
voller blauer Flecken ist.
Aber Amélie hat viel Erfahrung.
- Bist du drin?
Ja.
Dass Amélie an meiner Seite ist,
gibt mir viel Sicherheit.
Das tut gut.
Es kann ja sein, dass ich
eine Situation falsch einschätze
oder nicht mehr weiterweiss.
Ich weiss,
dass ich auf sie zählen kann.
Es läuft durch.
- Ich sehe es nicht.
Doch, es fliesst. Ja. Sieht gut aus.
Frau Mayor, ich stehe auf.
Könnten Sie das bitte halten?
Ja.
- Sagen Sie, wenn alles durch ist.
Über den Berg ist er noch nicht.
Möglicherweise
kriegt er noch einen Schlaganfall.
Wenn ein Problem gelöst ist,
kann schon das nächste kommen.
Für Fanny
geht der Stress also weiter.
Gut.
* Stöhnen *
Ich werde ... Ja, okay.
Postfiliale Montblanc in Genf.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Seit vier Jahren arbeitet Rebecca
jeden Samstag am Postschalter.
So finanziert sie
ihre Pflegefachausbildung.
Aber heute trägt sie ihre gelbe Bluse
zum letzten Mal.
Bald geht ihr neues Leben
als Pflegefachfrau los.
Es ist mir
noch nicht so ganz bewusst.
Aber die Aufregung spüre ich,
weil ich das nicht alles
vergebens gemacht haben möchte.
Aber es wird jetzt sicher konkret.
Nehmen wir noch einen Kaffee?
Rebecca wartet auf ihre Kolleginnen
und Kollegen -
für die Verabschiedung.
Marie taucht als Erste auf.
Sie war schon immer
völlig ungeschickt. Immer.
Das kommt schon gut,
liebe zukünftige Patienten.
Ich passe auf.
Sie ist eine sehr sensible Person.
Wir haben so viel zusammen erlebt.
Ja ... Sie wird mir fehlen.
Schätzchen,
du bringst mich durcheinander.
Ach, du bist so lieb.
- Es gibt einfach Personen ...
... die man einfach braucht.
- Es gibt mich ja immer noch.
Hoffentlich. Aber es ist wichtig,
dass du stolz auf dich bist.
Du hast viel geleistet.
Sie war erst hier,
dann in der Migros,
dann hier,
hat ihre Ausbildung gemacht ...
Das ist ...
Du kannst sehr stolz sein.
- Ja.
Ich habe sicher
keine geregelten Arbeitszeiten mehr.
Ich muss sogar
an den Wochenenden arbeiten.
Dafür gefällt mir meine Arbeit.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe,
freue ich mich auf die Arbeit.
Das ist hier nicht der Fall.
Darum ist es gut, dass ich gehe.
Wir sind wieder bei Fanny und Alfred,
der wegen einer Unterzuckerung
knapp dem Tod entging.
Seine Frau Josiane hilft mit
und hält den Beutel mit dem Zucker.
(Alfred) Ich mag nicht mehr.
- Es ist fast durch.
Wie viel Gramm hast du gesagt?
- Also ... Gut, wir können aufhören.
Jetzt wird der Blutzuckerwert
wieder kontrolliert.
Er ist schon
von 1,9 auf 9 hochgekommen.
Und wie von Zauberhand
kommt Alfred wieder zu sich.
Herr Mayor, sind Sie wieder bei uns?
Grüezi.
Was wollt ihr?
- Wir sind Sanitäterinnen.
Guten Tag.
- Ich brauche keine Ambulanz.
Offenbar schon.
Sie waren massiv unterzuckert.
Sie hatten eine Unterzuckerung.
Einen Schlaganfall
kann man jetzt ausschliessen.
(Josiane) Er hört nicht gut.
- Ist er hörbehindert?
Ja, auf dem rechten Ohr.
Wenn er das Hörgerät
nicht drin hat ...
(Laut) Herr Mayor,
Sie waren unterzuckert.
Sie hatten ...
Entschuldigung. Tut mir leid.
Ich musste schauen,
ob Sie auf Schmerz reagieren.
Offensichtlich.
- Wir setzen Sie jetzt auf.
Er reagiert wieder.
- Wir setzen Sie auf den Stuhl.
Dann ist Ihnen wohler.
- Da ist der Stuhl.
Alfred ist ziemlich unfreundlich
zu den Rettungssanitäterinnen.
Dabei sind sie gekommen,
um sein Leben zu retten.
Sie sind sicher müde.
- Kommen Sie.
Fast geschafft.
- (Alfred) Langsam, langsam.
Er litt und verstand noch gar nicht,
um was es ging.
Wir waren einfach sein Boxsack,
in den er reinschlagen konnte.
Das war ein Schock für ihn.
Er muss das Ganze erst mal verdauen.
Das ist halt so.
Das stört mich nicht.
Sie sind brutal.
Sie sind einer der wenigen,
die das sagen.
Kriegen wir kein Lächeln?
Ah, das ist aber schön, Herr Mayor.
Herr Mayor?
- Ja.
* Lachen *
Noch etwas.
- Sie sind brutal.
(Josiane) Noch weiter?
- Ja.
So ist gut.
* Stöhnen *
Herr Mayor, geht es Ihnen besser?
- Endlich etwas Ruhe.
Es gibt einen kleinen Stich.
Sie sind auch etwas dehydriert.
Wir müssen Sie rehydrieren.
6,7 - er geht wieder runter auf 4,1.
- Haben Sie Durst?
Wir gaben ihm 20 g Zucker.
Das ist enorm viel.
Aber das hatte er nötig.
1,9 ist tief.
Er verbrauchte das schnell.
Der Zuckerwert sollte
wieder stabil und normal sein,
ohne rauf- und runterzugehen.
Das wäre problematisch.
Jetzt sollte ein Glas Fruchtsaft
eigentlich ausreichen.
Schauen Sie, das ist Fruchtsaft.
Trotzdem muss man den Zuckerwert
alle 3-5 Min. kontrollieren.
Austrinken.
Langsam kommt Alfred
wieder auf die Beine.
Dafür bricht seine Frau Josiane
fast zusammen.
Ja, sehr gut.
- (Weinend) Das macht mich fertig.
Ich mache alles, wie man sollte ...
- Ja.
Das glauben wir Ihnen.
Er wollte die verdammten Zuckerwerte
einfach nicht messen.
Das wäre nicht passiert,
wenn er das gemacht hätte.
Und jetzt bin ich schuld.
- Nein.
Ich bin nicht schuld.
Ich kann nichts dafür.
Nein, das ist nicht Ihr Fehler.
Es ist schwierig.
Ich bin schon fast eine Kranken-
pflegerin. Ich mache es immer.
Sie könnten Hilfe verlangen.
- Braucht es nicht.
Ich habe es immer selber gemacht.
- Sie hatten Angst.
Das ist völlig normal.
- Ja, Angst.
Josiane ist erleichtert,
dass die Sanitäterinnen entscheiden,
ihren Mann ins Spital zu bringen.
Ein Moment zum Durchatmen.
Alfred will zu Fuss
zur Tragbahre gehen.
Gehen Sie weg.
- Ich lasse Sie runterkommen.
Einfach hinsetzen.
- Voilà.
Gut.
Der Stimmungswechsel ist auffällig.
Willst du einen Kuss? Heute Nacht
schlafen wir nicht zusammen.
(Alfred) Von mir aus.
Wenn es dir Freude macht.
(Josiane)
Wir sehen uns morgen wieder.
Ich stelle Sie etwas rauf.
Bei mir ist gut.
- Hoppla.- Schön.
Bis morgen.
- Bis morgen.- Das da rüber.
Dass das so schnell
wieder absolut gut sein kann,
habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Es beeindruckte mich,
wie schnell sich der Stoffwechsel
und der Körper erholten.
Eigentlich mussten wir ihn
nur wieder aufzuckern,
damit alles wieder perfekt lief.
Im Spital
kontrollierte man Alfred noch mal
und er konnte
noch am selben Abend nach Hause.
Universitätsspital Genf.
Hier macht Rebecca in der Abteilung
für Viszeralchirurgie
ihr letztes Praktikum.
Emelie, Rebeccas Ausbildnerin,
ist auch in der Pause.
In der Chirurgie
kann man sehr eigenständig arbeiten.
Die Ärztinnen und Ärzte
sind zwar da,
aber man ist häufig
alleine verantwortlich.
V.a. in der Nacht.
Da hat es nur einen Arzt
für das ganze Spital.
Da muss man erst mal
viel selber machen.
Emelie schüchterte mich anfangs ein.
Alle sagten, sie verlange superviel.
So: "Mach das, mach das ..."
Ich setzte mich unter Druck:
"Ich mache alles schlecht
und habe keinen Plan."
Ich plagte mich wirklich.
Hast du schon mal
einem Patienten geholfen,
der zum ersten Mal wieder aufsteht?
- Ja, ein-, zweimal.
Ich sage,
wie er aus dem Bett kommt.
Nicht am Galgen, sondern
auf die Seite und mit den Armen.
Liegen bleiben
bis ihm nicht mehr schwindlig ist.
Es ist wichtig,
dass die Pflegefachleute
die Patienten nach einer Operation
motivieren, wieder aufzustehen.
Wenn er sitzt, soll er so bleiben,
bis ihm nicht mehr schwindlig ist
und er sich okay fühlt.
Erst aufstehen,
wenn der Schmerz erträglich ist.
Sehr gut. Dann gehen wir.
Grüezi, Herr Vouilloz.
Wie geht es? Ich habe gehört,
Sie hätten Schmerzen.
Ja, beim Husten tut es so weh.
Als ich ins Zimmer kam,
hatte er wirklich starke Schmerzen.
Es ist schon die zweite
Bauchoperation für Raymond.
Er ist noch benebelt von der Narkose
und hat starke Schmerzen.
Ich gebe Ihnen
Dafalgan und Morphium.- Danke.
Tut es Ihnen überall weh,
oder nur auf einer Seite?
Nein, nur hier.
- Rechts?
Nur auf der rechten Seite.
- Verstanden.
Also ...
- Warum beginnst du unten rechts?
Weil es dort ... Entschuldigung.
Weil dort
der Übergang zum Dickdarm ist.
Ja, irgendetwas tut ihm da weh.
Eben, dort beginnt der Dickdarm.
Ja. Und beim Übergang zum Dünndarm
spürt man am besten, was los ist.
Ich höre Ihren Bauch ab.
Es wird etwas kalt.
Der Patient hat gemerkt,
dass Rebecca noch am Lernen ist.
Das macht es für Rebecca
manchmal schwierig.
Aber Raymond respektiert
die Arbeit der Pflegefachleute.
Perfekt.
Es rumort ziemlich dort drin.
Das erste Mal war ich einen Monat
auf der Intensivstation.
Das war noch viel schlimmer.
Wenn ich sehe,
wie sie sich um uns kümmern,
mit all den Alarmen,
die ständig erklingen,
weil man
an Geräte angeschlossen ist ...
Sie lachen trotzdem und sind
nie wütend. Das gibt Vertrauen.
Entschuldigung, ich muss.
Spürst du, wie hart es ist?
Und wie stark entzündet?
Mit einem Eisbeutel können
die Pflegefachfrauen rausfinden,
woher der Schmerz kommt.
- Spüren Sie die Kälte?- Nein.
Die linke Seite ist taub.
Darum spürt Raymond die Kälte nicht.
Aber auf der rechten Seite
spürt er sie.
Hier spürt er sie.
- Und wie.
Die Narkose
wirkt also nur auf einer Seite.
Einer Person,
die starke Schmerzen hat,
kann man nicht sagen, sie solle
aufstehen und nicht so tun.
Es wäre wichtig, dass er aufsteht,
aber wir wollen ihn nicht quälen.
Rebecca holt Hilfe.
Er hat starke Schmerzen.
Könnten Sie vorbeikommen?
Sie ruft die Schmerzspezialisten an.
Links spürt er es, rechts nicht.
- Dort tut es enorm weh.
Dort tut es ihm enorm weh.
Zwei Teams
sind auf Schmerzen spezialisiert
und kümmern sich
ausschliesslich darum.
In diesem Falle
mussten wir anrufen und erklären,
dass die Periduralanästhesie
nur auf einer Seite wirkt
und nicht - wie sie eigentlich
sollte - auf beiden Seiten.
(Mann) Auch wenn es einigermassen
geht, wenn Sie liegen ...
(Frau) Der Wert ist gut.
Die Anästhesiepflegefachfrau
programmiert auf Anordnung der Ärzte
eine Infusion mit Fentanyl,
einem sehr starken Schmerzmittel.
Das Prinzip ist, dass das Fentanyl
beständig reintröpfelt.
Und wenn Sie merken,
dass Sie sich bewegen möchten
oder husten müssen,
wirkt es in 5 Min.- Gut.
Es dauert nicht 20 Min.
wie bei der Periduralanästhesie.
Sie spüren es schneller, in 5 Min.
- Ja.
Verstanden.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wenn es wehtut, drücken Sie.
Im Team der Schmerzspezialisten
arbeitet auch
eine angehende Pflegefachfrau.
Sabina
macht die Ausbildung mit Rebecca.
Doch, es geht mir besser.
Ein Zusammentreffen
von zwei Freundinnen.
(Sabina)
Ich habe es vorher versucht.
Wir lernten uns
während der Ausbildung kennen.
Rebecca beschützte mich,
wenn ich Probleme hatte.
Sicher. Ist doch klar.
Wir waren während der ganzen
Pflegefachausbildung zusammen
und machten alles zusammen.
Wir wurden Freundinnen.
Richtige Freundinnen.
Es ist schön,
dass wir hier aufeinandertreffen
und uns zusammen
um den Patienten kümmern. Super.
Natürlich geht es ums letzte
Praktikum vor dem Berufseinstieg.
In vier Monaten
ist die Ausbildung fertig.
Dann müssen wir vorbereitet sein
und Verantwortung übernehmen.
Im ersten Lehrjahr
wird man noch etwas geschont.
Das kann hart werden, wenn man im
zweiten im Berufsalltag schnuppert
und im dritten Jahr schon mittendrin
ist und Verantwortung trägt.
In ein paar Monaten
sind wir Kolleginnen
und erwarten voneinander,
dass alles klappt.- Genau.
Wir alle haben schon mal geweint.
Oh ja.
- Vor Freude oder aus Stress.
Weil der Druck zu gross ist.
- Ich habe noch nicht geweint.
Das kommt noch.
- Ja?
Hoffentlich vor Freude.
Ich habe
noch nie vor Freude geweint
und hoffe,
ich habe das noch vor mir.
Nein.
Ich habe mich schon
über Lob gefreut.
Und gute Bemerkungen tun immer gut.
Ja, ich freute mich
und war stolz auf mich. Sicher.
Du hast die Kurve
gerade noch gekriegt.- Ja.
Oder so etwas.
Gerade hinstehen
und geradeaus schauen.
Wenn man auf den Boden schaut,
zieht es einen runter.
Noch gerader geht nicht.
- So ist tipptopp.
Dank des neuen Schmerzmittels
kann Raymond im Sitzen essen.
Wunderbar. Alles gut so?
Brauchen Sie noch etwas?- Nein.
Prima.
- Sie verwöhnen mich ja total.
Dann bis nachher.
- Bis später.- Guten Appetit.
In sechs Tagen kann Raymond
das Spital verlassen.
Seine Bauchoperation
ist gut verlaufen.
Klinik La Source in Lausanne.
In dieser Privatklinik
wird nicht gespart.
Die Leintücher sind schön straff
und zum Frühstück
gibt es Kaffee und etwas Süsses.
Hier eilt Hélène
durch die Chirurgieabteilung.
Auch für sie
ist es das letzte Praktikum.
Heute
muss sie mit Patientin Maryvonne
vorsichtig das Thema eines möglichen
Schlaganfalls ansprechen.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute Morgen?
- Ganz gut.
Hatten Sie eine gute Nacht?
- Nicht so.
Nicht so? Ja ... Man hat mir gesagt,
es sei schwierig gewesen.
Wenn man nicht mehr
so weiterleben kann ...
Mein Mann
hatte schon einen Schlaganfall.
Als die Ärztin sagte,
meine Herzrhythmusstörungen
würden das Risiko erhöhen -
das macht mir Angst.
Trotzdem versuchte ich zu schlafen,
aber das beschäftigte mich sehr.
Sie hat wahrscheinlich
nicht daran gedacht.
Für sie ist das Alltag.
Unser Dasein und unser Sterben.
Mein Mann
war drei Jahre teilweise gelähmt.
Aber das ist schon zehn Jahre her.
Seit dem Unfall
oder seit er gestorben ist?
Dass er weg ist.
- Dass er weg ist. Okay.
Ich kann mich nicht beklagen.
- Die Zeit heilt nicht alles.
Solche Gespräche gehören dazu.
Darum bin ich
so überzeugt von dem Beruf.
Es geht nicht nur
um die Gesundheit des Körpers.
Auch die psychische Gesundheit
gehört zur Pflege.
Psychischer Stress oder Sorgen sind
ein wesentlicher Bestandteil davon.
Meine Mutter hatte
zwei oder drei kleine Hirnschläge.
So Mini... Sie wissen das ja.
Ja, aber ohne Folgeschäden.
Ja?
Sie wurde 101.
- Wow.
Vielleicht schützten sie sie
vor anderem.- Wer weiss.
Also.
Es kommt ein Pflaster auf die Wunde.
So.
Aber nicht zu eng.
Okay?
- Nicht zu eng. Okay.
Der erste war mir zu eng.
Das war nicht so angenehm.
Noch ein Kleber et voilà.
- Bestens.
Der sollte halten.
- Sicher.
Perfekt. Das war es. Ade.
Gut.
In der Privatklinik hat jeder Patient
seinen eigenen Arzt.
Hélène begegnet gerade dem Chirurgen,
der Maryvonne operiert hat.
Eine gute Gelegenheit,
um sich kennenzulernen.
Der ursprüngliche Bruch
ging hier durch.
Sehen Sie das?
Hier ist die Handfläche
und hier der Handrücken.
Es ist immer interessant,
weil sie mehr wissen.
Das hilft uns, auch wenn wir
nicht alles behalten können.
Sie haben eine grössere Kenntnis
der Medizin und Biologie als wir.
Das ist sehr aufschlussreich,
auch wenn man es
noch mal im Internet nachlesen muss.
Es ist immer spannend und man
lernt viel dazu bei den Gesprächen.
Das können wir
dem Patienten vermitteln.
Das sieht wie eine Gabel aus.
(Frau) Das sind Schrauben.
- Ein Laubrechen.
Der Arzt schaute mich schräg an.
"Ein Rechen?" Als wollte er sagen:
"Ich mache doch keine Rechen."
Das gefällt mir.
Es braucht doch etwas Humor.
Wir sollten doch nicht scheu sein,
wenn wir
etwas Lustiges zu sagen haben.
Okay.
Das sieht ein wenig so aus.
- Absolut.
Gut. Danke vielmals.
- Danke vielmals.
Gerne geschehen. Ade.
- Schönen Tag noch.
Grüezi. Grüezi.
- (Mann) Grüezi.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute Morgen?
- Schon besser.
Wirklich? Inwiefern?
Wenn ich so liege,
tut es weniger weh.
Roger hatte eine Rückenoperation,
weil er gestürzt war.
Wir haben rausgefunden,
dass Sie Schauspieler sind.
Ja.
Machen Sie das immer noch
oder sind das Tempi passati?
Nein, das mache ich seit 62 Jahren.
- Uff.
Sie sind sich
die Kamera also gewohnt.- Ja.
Der Beruf
motiviert mich dazu, weiterzumachen.
Auch im zarten Alter von 84 Jahren.
Aber ich stehe noch auf der Bühne
und gehe auf Theatertournee.
Ich habe ein Projekt,
später dieses Jahr,
darum muss ich gesund werden.
Darf ich Sie um etwas bitten?
- Ja.
Könnten Sie den Vorhang ziehen?
Es ist mir zu hell.
Den hier? Den grossen?
- Gerne.
Den vorderen? So?
- Ja. Ja, gerne.
Gerne noch etwas mehr.
- Noch mehr?
Merci.
- Gerne.
Das ist
das Schwierigste am Ganzen für mich:
dass ich total abhängig bin.
Schenken Sie mir bitte ein.
Wasser?
- Könnten Sie zwei Becher füllen?
Zwei Becher?
Ich hole gleich noch einen.- Bitte.
Mache ich.
- So habe ich sicher genug.
Bitte schön.
- Tausend Dank.
Nichts zu danken.
Am besten
kann man sich doch bedanken ...
... bei den Pflegerinnen
und Pflegern,
die sich ständig um einen kümmern,
wenn man so wenig wie möglich
klingelt und stört.
Also, wenn man sie z.B. fragt,
ob sie einem nicht von Anfang an
alles auf dem Tablett
so bereitstellen könnten,
dass man selber rankommt
und nicht zehnmal klingeln muss.
Sich einfach so organisieren,
dass man die Suppe nicht umwirft
und die Serviette
gleich angelegt wird.
Dass kein Glas runterfällt etc.
Ich finde, so kann man
ihnen am besten "Merci" sagen:
indem man
zusammenarbeitet und mitmacht.
Das ist wirklich schön.
Das höre ich zum ersten Mal
von einem Patienten.
Egal, wo wir sind,
wir denken immer daran,
dass wir noch mal schauen müssen,
oder ob sie etwas brauchen.
Aber dass sich jemand
Gedanken darüber macht,
dass er stören könnte oder nur
so viel wie nötig klingeln sollte,
weil wir so viel zu tun haben,
macht nicht jeder.
Das macht Freude.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Ade. Danke.
Gerne, danke Ihnen.
- Belle Hélène.
Also ...
Wenn ich zwischen einer Belle Hélène
und einem Spitzbuben wählen könnte,
wäre der Fall klar.
- Klar.
Aber Belle Hélène
klingt nicht schlecht.- Ja.
Sehr schmeichelhaft. Bis später.
- Merci.
Im Büro der Pflegefachleute
wird Vanessa verabschiedet.
Sie verlässt die Klinik.
Heute ist mein letzter Tag hier.
Richtig.
Neue Abenteuer erwarten mich.
Anders, aber sicher auch spannend.
- Sicher.
Während der Praktika
sind die jungen Pflegefachleute
schnell mit dem harten Berufsalltag
konfrontiert und stehen unter Druck.
Das entmutigt Hélène aber nicht.
Mit dem Beruf
hat man auch verschiedene Optionen.
Wenn es einem nicht gefällt,
kann man die Abteilung wechseln
und etwas Neues ausprobieren.
Ich sage das jetzt so.
Mal schauen,
wo ich in zehn Jahren bin.
Ich möchte offen sein
für andere Abteilungen,
oder das, was noch kommt.
Hier wird
auch jede Verabschiedung gefeiert.
Man muss den Abschied feiern.
- Muss ich das bis 20 Uhr tragen?
Vanessa muss die Verkleidung
bis am Schluss tragen.
Sie hat sich selbstständig gemacht
und wird in der Heimpflege arbeiten.
Grüezi. Tut mir leid,
dass ich so komisch aussehe.
Man hat mich verkleidet.
Es ist mein letzter Tag.
Wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe,
ging es mir auch so.
Hätte ich nicht hierhin gewechselt,
hätte ich den Beruf aufgegeben.
Man hat zu wenig Zeit
für sich selbst.
Es saugt einen
emotional und körperlich aus.
Es belastet das Familienleben
und einen selber.
Es braucht Zeit, bis man zugibt,
dass es nicht mehr stimmt.
Wie Vanessa,
die merkte, dass sie erschöpft ist.
Dann hat sie reagiert.
Jetzt macht sie etwas Neues
und wird aufblühen
und hervorragende Arbeit leisten.
Wenn man nicht aus dem Teufelskreis
ausbrechen kann ...
... wird man
eine schlechte Pflegefachfrau.
Spital Trois-Chêne in Genf.
In der Notaufnahme des Spitals
für Seniorinnen und Senioren
macht Lucas sein letztes Praktikum.
Das Ehepaar in Zimmer 7
ist gerade aufgewacht.
Guten Morgen.
- Morgen.
Ich bin Lucas und in der Ausbildung.
Ich kümmere mich um Sie.- Gut.
Anne-Marie ist hier,
weil sie völlig erschöpft ist.
Und Francis kam mit, weil er nicht
alleine zu Hause bleiben wollte.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute Morgen?
Ich bin etwas ausgeschlafener.
- Ja?
Ich konnte morgens etwas schlafen.
Anne-Marie ist 87.
Die ehemalige Uhrenmacherin kümmert
sich rund um die Uhr um ihren Mann.
Drücken Sie bitte
beide Hände ganz fest.
So fest, wie Sie können.
Sehr gut. Sie haben ja Kraft.
Beeindruckend.
- Ja.
Aber weniger in den Beinen.
- Ah, da haben Sie Mühe.
Sie ist übermüdet und erschöpft.
Sie kümmerte sich
mehr um ihren Mann als um sich.
Sie kam an einen Punkt,
an dem es für sie zu viel wurde.
Yamina, Lucas' Ausbildnerin,
will noch mehr wissen.
Frau Vuilleumier,
kümmern Sie sich um Ihren Mann?
Ja. Immer.
- Immer? Haben Sie keine Hilfe?
Nein.
Und wie geht das?
- Ich bin immer erschöpft.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Ich mache alles für ihn.
Er macht nichts.
Plötzlich konnte ich
nicht mehr und ...
... seit zehn Tagen
bin ich nur noch müde.
Ich kann nichts mehr machen.
Das ist die Situation.
Irgendwann muss man aufhören.
Voilà, so ist es.
- Man muss Hilfe holen.
Welche Hilfe hätte ich holen sollen?
Es gibt z.B. Leute,
die für Sie einkaufen.
Ja, wissen Sie, weil wir gerne ...
... gut essen, sind wir heikel.
Darum machen wir das selber.
Ich habe darauf gewartet,
dass die Restaurants aufmachen.
Aber das geht noch eine Weile.
Darum koche ich selber.
So ist das halt.
Darum musste ich einkaufen gehen.
Die sind klebrig,
das ist nicht praktisch.- Ja.
Pflegende Angehörige
haben häufig Mühe,
sich Hilfe zu holen,
weil sie denken, versagt zu haben.
Viele fühlen sich schuldig
und weinen, wenn sie den,
um den sie sich gekümmert haben,
ins Spital bringen.
Wir versuchen,
ihnen die Schuldgefühle auszureden
und ihnen klarzumachen, dass sie
diese Grenzen akzeptieren müssen.
Tatsächlich sind die Angehörigen,
die pflegen, häufig kränker.
Manchmal sterben sie auch früher
als die eigentlichen Patienten.
Weil sie erschöpft sind?
- Genau.
Sie haben eine sehr nette Frau,
Herr Vuilleumier.- Ja.
Wie lange
sind Sie schon verheiratet?
Schon 60 Jahre.
- 63.
73, voilà.
Entschuldigung, 63.
Wir haben 1958 geheiratet.
- Richtig.
63 Jahre.
- Das gibt es selten.
Das gibt es selten.
Das Bild, das sie vermitteln,
ist das eines Ehepaars
mit einer klaren Rollenverteilung.
Mit dem Monsieur,
der auf dem Sofa sitzt,
seinen Kaffee trinkt
und die Zeitung liest,
und sie macht ständig etwas:
putzen, in der Küche etc.
Zu Hause ist er mir nicht im Weg.
Er liegt meistens im Bett.
Typisch Mann, oder?
Da bin ich nicht einverstanden.
Lucas hat keine Zeit
zum Argumentieren.
Er muss sich
beim Blutabnehmen konzentrieren.
Machen Sie bitte eine Faust.
Ich steche in drei, zwei ...
Yamina hilft ihm verständnisvoll.
- Warte kurz.
Du bist etwas daneben. Du musst
die Vene recht runterziehen. Dort.
Genau. Perfekt.
Sehr gut.
Nicht mehr?
Es gibt Tage,
an denen es einfacher geht
und Tage,
an denen man keine Chance hat.
Und man weiss nicht,
warum es so ist.
Einige Leute haben auch Venen,
die man sehr schwer findet.
War er vorsichtig?
- Ja.
Sehr gut.
- Sie müssen nicht nett sein.
Nein, so war das nicht gemeint.
- Ich kann noch viel verbessern.
Alle Pflegenden hier
sind so freundlich.
Ich komme in ein paar Minuten
wieder.- Ist gut.
Es geht Richtung Labor.
In der Notaufnahme
muss das Pflegefachpersonal
den Ärzten in wenigen Minuten
die Resultate einer Blutanalyse
und Urinprobe zur Verfügung stellen.
Theoretisch ist es klar.
Aber praktisch?
Man muss es
nach einer Minute anschauen.
Dreh es um.
- Da unten?
Schau, da unten ist blau.
- Ah ja.
Und oben schön violett.
So siehst du die Leukozyten.
Es ist nicht so einfach
mit diesen Teststreifen.
Ich bin froh, dass ich mich auf
meine Kolleginnen verlassen kann.
Die haben mehr Erfahrung
und können mir sagen,
wie ich das Resultat finde
und wie ich es richtig lese.
Du kannst es im Kopf behalten
oder aufschreiben.
Ich schreibe es lieber auf.
Schau.
Keine Angst, in ein paar Jahren
kannst du es dir ohne Aufschreiben
merken.- Hoffentlich.
Anne-Marie
hat Probleme mit einer Niere.
Lucas diskutiert
mit Hilfspfleger Cyril,
wie es weitergeht für das Ehepaar.
Ob wir wohl
für beide ein Zimmer finden?
Ein Paar kommt nicht
ins gleiche Zimmer.- Nicht?
Weisst du, warum?
- Ich habe eine Vermutung.- Warum?
Wenn nötig,
kommen sie in den gleichen Stock.
Damit sie sich sehen können.
Aber nicht ins gleiche Zimmer,
weil sich dann die eine Person
wieder um die andere kümmert
und sich nicht erholt.
- Das wäre keine Erholung.
Der pflegende Angehörige
soll sich ausruhen.
Absolut.
Das Ziel ist, dass sie aus
den Rollen ...- ... rauskommen.
Richtig.
Du findest das grausam.
- Ja, schon.
Im ersten Moment
findet man das keine gute Idee.
Man möchte sie in ein Zimmer legen.
Sie sind 60 Jahre verheiratet
und waren immer zusammen.
Man möchte sie zusammenlassen.
Aber das ist keine gute Idee.
- V.a. für sie nicht.
Ja.
Sonst steht sie wieder auf
und kümmert sich um ihn.
Dann ändert sich nichts.
- Es würde sie mehr erschöpfen.
Immer an die Angehörigen denken.
- Alles klar.
Immer an die
pflegenden Angehörigen denken.
Wichtig.
Hast du Lust auf einen Quark?
- Oh ja.
Zeit für eine Pause in der Cafeteria.
Fühlst du dich wohl
in der Notaufnahme?
Eigentlich schon.
- Eigentlich? Was meinst du damit?
Weil ich nicht gerne früh aufstehe.
Daran musst du dich gewöhnen.
- Ich arbeite dran.
Damit ich euch morgens
lächelnd begrüsse.
Aber wenn ich
um 21 Uhr schlafen gehe,
sehe ich jung schon sehr alt aus.
- Wenn du um 5 Uhr auf musst ...
Ich weiss.
Ich ziehe um.
In Zimmer 7 müssen sich Anne-Marie
und ihr Mann verabschieden.
Während Anne-Marie wegen der Nieren
im Spital bleiben muss,
geht Francis
in ein Rehabilitationszentrum.
Passen Sie auf sich auf.
- Ja.
Ich sage bewusst nicht
"Auf Wiedersehen".
Das mit der besten Absicht.
- Verstanden.
Ich wünsche Ihnen
auch gute Gesundheit.
Frau Vuilleumier,
ich wünsche Ihnen auch alles Gute.
Achten Sie auf sich.
Nutzen Sie die Zeit,
um sich zu erholen.- Merci.
Ihr Mann ist in guten Händen.
- Ja.
Um ihn mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
- Super.
Merci vielmals.
- Achten Sie auf sich.
Ich schätze Sie sehr. Merci.
Die Geschichte
gibt einem einen Stich ins Herz.
Wenn man sich das bewusst macht:
63 Jahre ist viel Zeit,
um zusammenzuleben.
So eine Trennung kann Angst machen.
Man weiss ja nicht,
was die Zukunft bringt.
Auch wenn sie nur eine gewisse Zeit
im Spital ist und er woanders.
Da kommt einem die Zeit
wohl länger vor,
als wenn beide im Spital wären.
Die Ungewissheit
macht sicher beiden Sorgen.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass ich ohne ihn bin.
Oder, Schatz?
Ich hoffe ...
- Kopf hoch.
... dass wir uns bald wiedersehen.
- Kommt gut.
Habe Vertrauen.
- Mhm.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Ade.
(Mann) Ich komme nachher.
In Zimmer 7? Ja, ist gut.
Ade.
Das tut weh.
Ich habe ihn nie alleine gelassen.
Das merkt man.
Er war oft im Spital,
aber ich bis jetzt nie.
Ich mache mir keine Sorgen um sie.
Und um mich auch nicht.
Ich denke, ich bin in guten Händen.
Hoffe ich zumindest.
Zwei Wochen später kann Anne-Marie
das Spital verlassen.
Auch die Rettungssanitäterin Fanny
hat Feierabend.
Wir treffen sie zu Hause bei ihren
Eltern in Épendes im Kanton Fribourg.
Sobald sie
mit der Ausbildung fertig ist,
will Fanny
in eine eigene Wohnung ziehen.
(Mutter) Wenn die Kinder ausziehen,
haben wir unseren Job gemacht.
Das ist doch gut.
Sie sind unabhängig und können das
Leben so gestalten, wie sie wollen.
Das ist doch cool so, oder?
Das braucht Zeit.
Auch zu Hause kann Fanny jederzeit
über die 144 aufgeboten werden.
Sie gehört zu einer Gruppe
von freiwilligen Nothelfern.
Aber heute ist sie nicht auf Pikett.
Das Zusammensitzen am grossen Tisch,
wo viel los ist,
ist das Geheimnis
dieser unzertrennlichen Familie.
Fannys kleiner Bruder ist Bauer.
Der grosse Bruder ist Bergsteiger
und ihre Schwester Konditorin.
(Schwester) Woah, Papa, toll.
Ja, grossartig, Papa.
Tradition verpflichtet.
Beim Essen macht
immer mal wieder jemand einen Scherz.
Ist mit dem Kuchen alles in Ordnung?
- Ja, klar. Warum nicht?
Es nehmen alle davon.
- Er sieht auch sehr gut aus.
Ist das dein Ernst?
- Was ist?
Im Tortenstock des grossen Bruders
ist viel Senf drin.
Fanny hat Salz im Tee.
Aber nicht ernsthaft.
- Das schmeckt man doch nicht.
Das ist nicht der Punkt.
Fannys Mutter erzählt,
ihre Tochter sei schon immer
ein besonderes Mädchen gewesen.
Die Leute sagten immer, sie habe
eine besondere Ausstrahlung.
Irgendetwas an ihr
hat einfach alle fasziniert.
Sie fing an ...
... schon mit sechs
auf Leute zuzugehen.
Auch in der Klasse
kamen alle zu ihr,
wenn sie etwas hatten.
Auch in der Primarschule.
Wenn jemand verletzt war oder so ...
Es überrascht mich nicht.
Es passt, dass sie sich
für den Beruf entschieden hat.
Fanny liebt ihre Familie.
Aber sie selber
hat andere Zukunftspläne.
Ich möchte arbeiten.
Aber keine Familie.
Gotte oder Tante zu sein,
wäre kein Problem.
Aber eigene Kinder
müssen nicht unbedingt sein.
Zumindest in den nächsten Jahren.
Und dann ist es eh zu spät.
Ich sehe mich bei der Arbeit
für die nächsten 50 ...
Moment, nicht 50.
Die nächsten 40 Jahre.
40 Jahre
als Rettungssanitäterin arbeiten -
das ist Fannys Traum für die Zukunft.
Es sieht gut aus.
- Ja, mit einem Bruder wie mir ...
Nächste Woche:
Bei Lucas geht es um Leben und Tod.
Ich gebe Ihnen etwas Sauerstoff.
Hélène leistet psychologische Arbeit.
Was stresst Sie mehr? Die Operation
oder die Klaustrophobie? Beides?
Rebecca betreut
einen Patienten mit Autismus
und findet einen guten Draht zu ihm.
- Ich gehöre dir.
Fanny feiert
zum ersten Mal Weihnachten
als ausgebildete Rettungssanitäterin.
Es wird ein kurzes Weihnachtsessen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022